استثمار بقيمه ثمانيه مليارات دولار سيعيد
ليبيا الى واجهه انتاج الغاز في حوض
المتوسط
وسيشجع على جلب المستثمرين في قطاع النفط
والغاز
وسيحرك الاقتصاد الليبي هكذا وصفت المؤسسه
الوطنيه للنفط الليبيه توقيعها اتفاقيه
تطوير حقل غازي في حوض البحر الابيض
المتوسط مع شركه ان الايطاليه للنفط
والغاز يقدر احتياطي الحقلين بسته
التريليونات قدم المكعب سنويا اي بمعدل
انتاج يبلغ
850 مليون قدم المكعبات يوميا الحقيقه ان
المناخ الحالي الامني والسياسي يشجع شركات
النفط على مواصله نشاط الاستكشاف وعلى
مواسق نشاط الاستثمار هذه الاتفاقيه التي
وقعت في طرابلس هي الاولى من نوعها منذ
اكثر من 25 عاما
يزود اوروبا بموارد الطاقه
بين ليبيا وايطاليا حيث ان الطاقه تعطى
لاجل الاستقرار والنمو واني موجوده في
ليبيا منذ عام
في وقت سابق اعلنت مؤسسه النفط الليبيه ان
ليبيا ستحقق عائدا من هذا الاستثمار يراوح
بين 13 و18 مليار دولار وتسعى شركه ان
الموجوده في ليبيا منذ اكثر من 60 عاما
الى زياده عمليات استكشاف النفط والغاز في
ليبيا وشمال افريقيا الاستقرار في ليبيا
من شان ان يفتح الماء المجال امام المزيد
من اتفاقيات النفط والغاز همم وبالتالي
المزيد من الغاز الى اوروبا والمزيد من
الارباح وهمم مجالات الصناعيه اكثر في
ليبيا تسعى ايطاليا الى توسيعه شركتها مع
ليبيا في مجال استكشاف الغاز والتصديره
خصوصا ان ليبيا تشه استقرارا امنيا ملحوظا
في مناطق انتاج النفط والغاز وتطمح الى
استغلال فرص ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه عالميه
مع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا احمد خليفه
الجزيره طرابلس